well the violent left is a growing force
in American politics and life from here
in Washington to Portland Oregon to the
Bay Area and yet even now movements like
in Tifa remain mostly mysterious to news
consumers you most the time to see them
when they riot a couple 30-second clips
and that's about it what is it like
inside these groups and what motivates
their members Conor Barnes spent years
as part of an anarchist community later
left the movement and has published a
pretty remarkable essay about his
experiences in quill at which is
excellent by the way Conor Barnes joins
us tonight Connor thanks a lot for
coming on I was really struck by your
piece I don't think I've ever read an
account I know I've never read an
account of what it's like to be at the
center of something like this by the way
I have no idea what your politics are
now I'm not even gonna ask you but I was
interested that you described this as
like a religious community almost mm-hmm
there is a really strong faith-based
component you become absolutely sure
that you're right and nothing's gonna
sway you from it you've you've set your
course you figured it out so it didn't
seem from your description like there
were a lot of other inputs coming into
the cell it seemed almost totally self
referential you talk only to people
you're in it with what are the things
that you convinced yourself of or were
convinced of when you were in this cell
mm-hmm oh just gosh everything you were
able to find what was wrong with
everything from school to government to
police to any interaction people had you
can find what's wrong with it it's a
it's not a very happy way to live what
was your view of violence so violence
there's a there's a shifty way people
talk about it direct action and
diversity of tactics which is a subtle
way of saying if somebody wants to be
violent we're going to turn our head and
be okay with it
so it's not a non-violent movement no no
no oh how did she get into it I was a
pretty unhappy teenager and I'm told
that happens a lot to teenagers and I
went looking for
explanation and I ended up just reading
a lot of radical literature and found
more and more radical literature until I
found things that explained that
happiness wasn't something you had much
control over capitalism was keeping you
down yes what what spurred you to leave
it mmm there were I'd say there were two
components there was there are nasty
people in the scene and I got mixed up
with somebody and that kind of shook me
out of my headspace and forced me to
reconsider things and I just started
reading wider and wider literature and
you know I encountered gradual things
that made me go oh that totally changes
you know that that can't be true you
know you you get shocked out of the cult
bit by bit huh huh interesting
Connor Barnes I just want to say again
to our audience if you haven't read this
piece it's on quill at it's just so
interesting I've never seen anything
like it I really appreciate your coming
in I should thank you oh thank you
talking